good morning Hank it's Tuesday this
video is an open letter to professional
youtubers but it's also for anyone who
wants to understand the challenges of
the fraud career of professional
influencing hi I'm John Green I write
books and I've been making youtube
videos for more than 12 years now also
I'm somewhat repulsed by the word
influencer it makes me feel like one of
the baddies in a dystopian novel which
to be fair maybe I am but the nice thing
about influencer is that it's accurate
if you have an audience you help shape
their worldview both when it comes to
like which goods and services to
purchase and when it comes to what to
believe and value that's a weird job and
today I want to share with you some
things I've learned about it first being
a professional person of the internet is
not like being a doctor or a lawyer or
whatever it's more like being a
professional athlete online careers are
unpredictable and they're often short
which isn't necessarily bad news by the
way like it can be wonderful to do many
things in your professional life but I
do think it's worth trying to learn
about stuff while you are a professional
influencer that can help you down the
road when you are professionally
something else whether that's social
media marketing or post-production or as
in my case writing secondly many of us
get absolutely no financial education in
school and professional influencers tend
to be young and inexperienced with money
which one can make it difficult to
figure out how to prioritize financial
stuff and to leaves people vulnerable to
exploitation even if like me you're
aggressively bad at math I really
recommend trying to learn more about
personal finance by reading books like
Gabby Dunn's batted money listening to
podcasts like Planet Money and watching
YouTube shows like two cents in the
financial diet as for the people who
make you money agents and managers can
be wonderful advocates but remember they
have no lifelong investment in you if
you cease to be a lucrative relationship
for them they can find it different you
a younger and hipper and more
influential influencer but you are your
only you and ultimately that means you
have to be the person to balance
short-term interest and long-term
interest when it comes to issues like
when to turn down unsavory sponsorships
speaking of which third when it comes to
money opportunities Hank always asks me
two questions is this in line with our
goals for our community and are we
adding more value than we're capturing
we've made lots of mistakes along the
way but from what kind of shirts to sell
to whether to promote loot boxes I do
think we benefit a lot from asking those
questions okay fourth this did not
happen because you work harder than
anyone else or because you are more
talented you are talented and you do
work
but you have also been fortunate you're
fortunate to have high-speed Internet
and access to editing software and
you've also gotten lucky along the way
in innumerable ways luck does not
nullify hard work but hard work also
does not nullify luck fifth you are a
person those who love your work will
naturally be inclined to think of you as
more than a person which can be
intoxicating it's nice to hear that
you're a literal God or the best
fortnight or vlogger or whatever noun is
currently being personalised but there
will also be people who think you're
less than human who say that your
literal trash we don't talk about this
much because it can seem like
ingratitude but receiving online hate
can be really scary and painful and I'm
sorry if you have to live with it in my
experience it's really important to find
places where you can be a person whether
that's an anonymous reddit account or
god forbid offline because otherwise you
can start to believe both those who
think you're more than a person and
those who think you're less than one
lastly as my brother likes to say
diversify your identity in this world so
much of your life can become your job
your friends and family can be involved
in your job when you take a walk you're
doing your job if you Instagram it your
life and work can become so completely
intertwined that you stop thinking of
yourself as for instance John Green
person husband father AFC Wimbledon
sponsor a valid Hufflepuff etc and begin
to think of yourself as just John Green
youtuber no career can healthfully carry
all your identity let alone one as weird
and unpredictable as this and so dear
influencer I wish you the algorithms
wind in your sails and a flood of new
followers but most of all I wish you a
long and varied life of making helpful
things with nice people Hank I'll see
you on Friday